one man in more than a hundred dead in
one day they're memorials among the
bricks they use to defend themselves
one son with one aim now not only to
avenge his father's death eight years
ago but ready to defend his homeland
from the might of russia's military
father tried help
vladimir bondarchuk points to where
snipers were posted he's an i.t engineer
and a military reservist and expects to
be called up very soon
like so many who died here vladimir's
father sergey didn't look like a
revolutionary he was a schoolteacher
sergey was alive when his fellow
protesters rushed him to a makeshift
clinic in a hotel reception area he'd
been shot in the back and died later
i know
who
guilty in this situation and part of
regime
yanukovych and first of all it's a
russian federation and
of course putin
on the morning of february the 20th 2014
a truce was broken as police suddenly
retreated then came a barrage of bricks
from the protesters answered with
gunfire in hindsight they call it the
revolution of dignity on that day as i
witnessed it was anything but dignified
once again the square is a battle zone
the truce had seemed tenuous from the
outset here now the front line has moved
everywhere you look there are casualties
maidan euromaidan freedom square the
angel monument words names symbols that
for many years have made vladimir putin
seethe he's fanatical about ukrainians
being part of russia
yet this country now has more than 30
years of independence behind it it may
be a democracy that's imperfect but the
vast majority of ukraine's people turned
their back on soviet autocracy and want
to be part of europe with membership of
nato for protection
but at what cost there's conflict in the
east of the country with russian-backed
separatists and the annexation of crimea
by russia are you prepared to die for
this cause
yes are we ready and
all other ukrainian people
are ready for this and uh
it's most important protect
our country our families and
for this we did everything what we we
can
more than 14 000 lives already lost in
conflict vladimir and many others know
only too well the human costs so far
could be dwarfed by all-out war
andrew simmons al-jazeera kiev